toi allez
vas-y c'est
ça
derrière moi
je la vie à gauche
derrièreen
un peu serré là non peut-être je sais
pas je te laisse
faire n'écoute pas ce que je te
DIRIS allez on va commencer à monter
Eric
hein voilà il a toute l'empilade
derrière de le point
ou alors c'est trop loin ouais voilà on
recommence de mer non c'est on
reste comme ça que sinon passer tant
pis vasy maintenant tu bien sûr éidment
passer
le sur la gauche c'est bien ouais ch il
a pas
plus fa GAE quand
même fr Fran bon attendsrêteveci tu peux
pas les faire là tuas tu vas tu vas les
souffler les pauv bateau là ok
coupe vas-your
tour pas
trop je pense que ça vibre non
pourquoi c'est quand un peu de
travers bien droit tu vas point vibrer
pr soleil pr dans la
gueuleo par soleil à mon
avis
ouis c'est sû c'est s ça VI la vibre
à
[Musique]
T
monte un petit peu monte un tout petit
peu souffles un
[Musique]
peu voilà c'est
bon
remonter un peu tu souffles un
peu
[Musique]
voilà
c'est bon pour
toi le gros groupoup plus à
droite
allez